at the moment is the only small horse
breed that survives in the Greek islands
it's possible that some courses at some
point went to the island and they
adapted to the local conditions and
that's why they are smaller from far
away you don't realize that they are so
small because they are well proportioned
they have the same proportions as a
larger horse a breed definition of this
green horse is no taller than 116 the
withers preferably smaller no white
markings of any kind so no white stars
no white socks to be a block color Bei
done dark brown a thicker mane and tail
which is more kind of non-domesticated
course strong hard who's expressive eyes
not a particularly pretty face but a
handsome head in the island there was a
large much larger population until in
the second world war and a few thousand
horses and they were used in agriculture
we were concerned about one the welfare
of the scaring horses that they were not
in great shape they weren't in good
condition but two really concerned about
and not being a definable breed that
there were very few ponies that looked
the same
we became both interested from a
conservation perspective but also from a
welfare perspective and then starting
very much was like but within that we
have to have an education perspective to
change local people's opinion about
what's carrying horses how we should
look after it how we should protect it
the university got involved because they
wanted to reconstruct the pedigrees
especially for a breed that is small in
numbers it is important to know the
relationships between
the animals so that inbreeding is
avoided when we first started off we
were breeding and that was our main
concern from the horses that we've bred
that we've kept we then could begin to
train those horses for riding train
those horses for driving train their
horses flat ground agility and so
exploring different ways that the Pony
has value in a contemporary society and
in a society such as Greece where
there's not a long history of equine
activities by moving on the ponies that
we've bred I'm now able to go off into
the big wide world and hopefully promote
the scary and Pony and the Ireland we
can then breed with the mares that we've
bred which are better quality than the
mayor's we originally had to produce
hopefully even better quality scurrying
horses
yeah